I'm good how are you pretty good you
said you were a Muslim yeah yeah yeah
obviously for my name I was raised
Christian but I converted he was raised
Christian yeah and converted to
Islam yeah what in the world came over
you uh truth truth Ain't No Way truth
came over you and you
left I I was asking my pastors with uh
why why I felt with in contradictions
the Bible and they couldn't elucidate
sufficiently so I was like yeah this
doesn't make sense did you say atheism
never made sense to me either so I
thought Islam is the most rational
religion what is it about Islam that is
true for you U I was going to ask you
what what is the lie because the main
claim is that God is one isn't it so how
can you even the main claim is that you
need to believe in Muhammad and follow
him and submit to him before you can
have faith in anything okay um so it it
said several times that Muhammad's just
the reminder and he's not brought
anything new and actually the first
thing a false prophet would do is like
make it all about himself and Muhammad
from the historical records banned
everyone from actually making images of
him so in my mind that's something no
false prophet would do because obviously
a false prophet would be doing all the
fake Revelations for ego
are you they want people to I'm quranist
to be honest you're a
quranist yeah yeah yeah so to have a
field my religion is based on the Quran
so you don't follow any Hadith um I mean
I think there're like a lot of them
probably are sayings of of the prophets
prophet of the Prophet peace be upon him
but some of them probably like like it's
not God's word directly it's like passed
down um where where
essentially so it's not it's not 100%
true so that's not a religion it's like
okay so just just a curiosity where did
you get it from that Muhammad banned
people from making images of him um that
that's just been passed down in the in
the Traditions like every I mean that's
just common knowledge isn't it well no I
I'm not saying all the Hadith are false
I'm not saying they're all false I'm
just saying it's not a religion huh how
do how do you know that particular
Hadith is true
because why would they make it up why
would they make anything up in the HBY
oh some things like they can make it up
because certain people have vested
interests in getting a custom adopted in
in the faith or whatever or maybe like a
ruler wants to get his way and so he
decides to add add something to the he
conspires with a few people and adds
something to the Hadith and I know
there's like a Hadi science but they
have weeded out some fake ones in the
past so there's no guarantee that all of
them are authentic and I just feel like
yeah you're you're you're literally
you're cherry picking the Hadith and you
don't don't you don't have like a a
basis of judging what Hadith is true or
not it's only just upon maybe like you
know a personal assumption that you'll
have no I'm not saying like the Hadith I
think if you want to follow them they
can be like a good like case law like um
people did this in the past you can use
it for like jurist Prudence or whatever
to say to inform your your judgments in
the present but it's not like a religion
it's just like because my the the Quran
claims to be like a complete book a
complete guidance and after it was
revealed um it said uh well the angel
said that uh Allah has completed his
favor upon you and given you your
religion so like for me the the Quran is
sufficient as religion and if you want
to follow theth as like case law and
what people did before and that's fine
okay so the so the Quran so you
mentioned how like the Hadith it
mentions that Muhammad forbade people
from making images of him and yeah in
the same collection of Hadith in the you
know the Authentic
Collection his wife Aisha who he really
loved who he was really close to he
loved her right that was his
favorite she said she made mention and
said it seems like like your lord
beckons at your will or fulfills your
desires beckons at your desires so using
the Hadith we can kind of see that
Muhammad does use Allah as a means to
get what he wants So based on your your
logic what did he want exactly um
certain women certain Goods certain
Authority okay but um wasn't he he was a
wealthy Trader before and he was from a
good family in the K tribe before he
started getting Revelations so he
already had like a good standing in
society and he threw that all away for
the chance of
authority he didn't he didn't he didn't
though have good standing in society yet
he wasn't nobody he wasn't really
anybody yet I've heard from all all the
historical sources say he was like yeah
his family had a good standing in in the
kage society and he was a he was a
traitor of some kind I believe so you're
not Quran only no I'm just saying um
that's just based on the historical
sources is what I understand to be the
case and in the beginning he obviously
didn't succeed because he he got driven
out of his homeland yes based on these
same historical sources Muhammad
according to his wife Allah seemed to
give him whatever he wanted and becking
at his desire so you you don't accept
that he had to flee to
Ethiopia because they were kill him no
no no no I don't I don't not accept that
you know I'm just saying we we need to
we need to be able to if we're going to
use Islamic history right and and appeal
to it then let's do that but like so
when I bring up something let's not say
oh when I do that you're quranist or
that's that that could be or not be you
know what I'm saying and not picking and
choose and I won if we're going to if
that's our if that's a source that's
reliable for us to be using in this
conversation
let's use it if it's not let's throw it
all out and just be Quran only all right
yeah yeah just throw it all out to be
honest because based on based on the
book The the Quran itself is very
consistent with like what Christians say
they believe as well because well that
my question was what what do you object
to exactly is that God is one like what
else does it really assert that that God
doesn't have a son okay but you
well yeah but that's just to clarify I
guess to well people who take it
literally and
amorphizing God because like obviously
you don't believe God has a son in the
human sense do you I don't believe he
had sex no but I do believe that he has
a begotten son whose name is Jesus
begotten meaning what meaning that he
proceeded from the father's own Essence
but didn't everything proceed from the
father's essence no so if God so God was
there at the beginning and he's all that
exists where did everything come from he
created it
exilo where out of nothing he created it
by his power it doesn't come from his
Essence finite things cannot come in
intrinsically from the infinite but
finite things cannot come from the
infinite but you do believe that he
breathed his Spirit into into Adam so
like his spirit is what animated Adam at
the least based on the Bible you believe
you believe that you believe that Adam's
spirit is uncreated I I believe that
life comes from Allah and all all life
is dependent on his his life we borrow
our reality from the one reality at the
end of the day if God is real you
believe is creat God in the Quan says he
he is the truth and he created
everything out of Truth uh therefore he
created everything out of his own
existence like it's amazing Jesus says
he's the truth too isn't that crazy
right so when I was going to ask so what
what is your so what is your actual
complaint against Islam that God is one
what my complaint against Islam is that
the Quran contradicts what the prophets
teach it contradicts what Jesus and the
rest of the prophets taught Jesus taught
that God has a begotten son that he is
the the begotten Son of God the Quran
says nope you're are not Jesus is not
the Son of God matter of fact nobody is
a Son of God in any sense it says the
only way that you can come to Allah is
as a slave not a son so it knocks out
any figurative or literal or any
allegorical whatever sense that you can
be a son of Allah and he be your father
Jesus even says Jesus even says in the
Bible that he is a slave of God
essentially he said whatever God bids me
to do that I do and whatever he bids me
to say that I say of myself I don't have
any power like he doesn't
say please you're misquoting Jesus I got
to stop you you're misquoting Jesus he
never says without him I have no power
he doesn't say any of that what he does
say he said of myself I can do nothing
there you goise so by myself I can do
nothing only what I see the father doing
for whatever the son do um whatever the
father does the son does it the same way
so Jesus just said that he doesn't work
alone he cannot work alone because he's
in he's Inseparable from the father they
cannot be separated so he can't do
anything by himself he's not you know
doesn't work separately from the father
perfectly United but also at the same
time he says that whatever the father
can do he can do yeah okay so when he
says whatever the father bids me to do
that I do whatever he bids me to say
that I say that's the definition of a
Slave actually he doesn't say that
because he doesn't say
that that is well it's not verbatim but
that's the essence of what he said well
you you quote it then what did he say I
I just quoted you so he just says the
son can do nothing by himself but only
what he sees the father doing for
whatever the father does that the son
does it likewise the same way so he just
said that he can't work separately from
the father however whatever the father
can do he can do it the same way and he
continues he says for just as the father
gives life so the son gives life to
whomever he Wills I'm pretty sure it
does say wherever wherever I see the F
what does he say he says wherever the
father bids me say I say or something
like that like and also he says he says
something he says something along the
lines of you know you know as I hear I
judge these words are not but the one
who sent me stuff like that
okay what you're referring to yeah okay
so let's assume whatever the father told
him to do he did that's the definition
of a slave right
because I I wouldn't say that that's a
definition of a s slave per se um I
would say that that's a
def that's it's a servant but let me ask
you this children serve their parents
right right they do what their parents
say they do what their parents told them
to do right so children are Servants of
their parents you can say they're slaves
of their parents but they're not merely
servants they're they're not merely
slaves they are children they are Sons
and Daughters of their parents so saying
God also cares for him but he is an
obedient servants essentially he's a
servant he is a servant but he's not
merely a servant he's God's son
Sons serve their their fathers so Jesus
was doing a good he's a good son he
serves his father now just because he
serves God doesn't take away his identi
his identity as the Son of God it's just
showing that he's a good son okay um but
could could Jesus disobey the father
would he disobey the father nope he is
in perfect uni Unison with the father
they have the same will so that he
cannot go against they can't go against
each other they have the same un uh will
perfect Unison so my my point in in
showing this is that there's a different
like let me just ask you you you
understand now that there is a
difference between a slave and a son
right um well you can be both both right
you could you could be a a slave it even
says in in Proverbs it says um bring
your servant up as kindly from a child
and then you have a son at the end or
something like that in Proverbs I think
well I'm not I'm not sure about can but
but just just going about you're right
you can be biblically you can be both a
servant and a son so it says Jesus
answered them truly I say to you
everyone who practices sin is a slave to
sin the slave does not remain in the
house
forever the son remains forever so if
the sun sets you free you will be free
indeed right so you see how even Jesus
makes a distinction between a slave and
a son slave does not remain in the house
forever but the son remains
forever but not just that but the son is
also an inheritor or an heir of his
father's household right yeah so there's
a there's a difference yeah like I said
you could be both like yeah he's not
just a slave he's also God God um
favored him so in that sense he's no say
what he is he's not just a he's his son
right okay but when you say son it it's
not like God you know impregnated a
woman and gave birth to him so it's not
a son in the sense that humans
understands children the way it's not an
an anthropomorphic son so that's the
only reason to avoid using the word son
he he's begotten Son of God he says
didn't didn't it say when the Dove came
on him this day have I begotten you so
he's basically no it does and it says
this is my beloved Son in whom I well
please it doesn't say today I've
begotten you there didn't it say that no
on this day begotten you know all right
fair enough look John
3:16 you said you were a Christian so
you know this for God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son
begotten the Quran says neither begotten
right yeah so what do you mean begotten
that's what I want to understand I
already told you he comes from the
father's Essence he is of the father he
sh the same nature as the father the
Quran says Allah doesn't beget nor is he
begotten so Muhammad in the Quran
directly contradicts what Jesus teaches
that God did be but isn't wasn't there
also a verse in John that said there's
three in heaven uh we bear witness and
not go
Tak to that has nothing to do with this
I want you to focus please Focus Jesus
said that he's the begotten son the
Quran denies that God the Quran denies
Jesus as being God's son especially and
it denies that that Allah
beets this direct contradiction to what
Jesus says it depends what you mean by
beget to be honest because you could say
God begot the whole world because he
created it show me in the Quran where it
says that Allah begot the world he
created the world so
if no show me where it says he begot it
well that's just semantics but it
depends what you mean that it's
semantics no words have meaning man and
when you're when Allah says he doesn't
beget you're saying oh well it depends
on what sense you mean so Allah doesn't
really mean that he doesn't be it means
that he does be just in a I'm saying he
creates but he doesn't he doesn't like
have a he doesn't have a consort where
that he has intercourse with to to beget
a son the way humans do
so not you know I'm just wondering if if
you even respect the Quran more than me
at this point does Allah be or not well
he creates but he doesn't have sex and
give birth to children that's or not
well look can you look up the definition
of beget does it mean I just want to
know if he begins that's all I want to
know no he he creates so he does not
begin if beget you mean create then he
does
beget thanks John I'm I'm I'mma just let
you go with this man if you're going to
have these wait wait wait I never even
got to my question actually we've just
been discussing random John don't cut me
off please at this point what you have
shown is that you're dishonest
intellectually you're dishonest with
your own verses you can't be honest
about what your own verses say and so
because of that you waste my time you
waste my time man so I'm surprised
you're angry
continue this conversation with you if
you're going to be dishonest about your
own text so why why am I dishonest
because I'm just saying the way I am
wasting my time